our first presentation is going to deal
with Joseph Smith's run for the
presidency in 1844 Richard Bushman needs
no introduction I hate it when people
say that at conferences but it is in
this case true and also Sarah behringer
Gordon both of their BIOS are in your
programs and I hope you will give them a
warm welcome thank you on behalf of all
of the participants in all of you thanks
to jen and randy for bringing us
together and thanks for the Institute
very imaginative and vital groupon
columbia campus and we're very pleased
to be here under your auspices Jen on
May seventeenth 1844 the Democrats met
in Baltimore to select james k polk as
their presidential candidate on the very
same day at navo illinois another
convention met in the office of Joseph
Smith to formally nominate the Mormon
prophet for the same office that night
Smith's friends lit a barrel of tar in
front of his house and twice carried him
around the fire while a band filled the
air with music the tar burning was
largely a symbolic event to publicize a
campaign that had been moving forward
for four months the 12 apostles of the
church had first nominated Smith on
january twenty ninth after a frustrating
fall when the five prospective
candidates of both parties and refused
to promise the Mormons protection from
their enemies in November of 1843 Smith
had posed the question to each of them
what will be your rule of action
relative to us as a people none of them
had answered satisfactorily clay said he
could not bind himself to any
constituent
see in advance of the election Calhoun
said typically the case does not come
within the jurisdiction of the federal
government igniting explosion of
vexation from Smith the state's rights
doctrine are what feeds mobs they are a
dead carcass a stink the Mormon
newspaper the times and seasons
accounted for Smith's candidacy by
explaining that under existing
circumstances we have no other
alternative and if we can accomplish our
object well if not we shall have the
satisfaction of knowing that we have
acted conscientiously Smith himself said
he would never have loud his friends to
nominate him if the saints could have
had the privilege of enjoying our
religious and civil rights he presented
himself as a protest candidate the
sequences of events in 1843 in 1844 can
be seen as an encapsulated version of
the overall trajectory of Smith's
political career reluctance followed by
involvement was the pattern in the
presidential election year and the
pattern that he had followed over the
course of his life he did not want to
get mixed up in politics in 1844 or in
1830 but in been drawn in by the needs
of the church it began his religious
clear career as a millenarian with no
interest in America as a nation when the
Church of Christ was organized in 1830
the expectation of an immediate return
of Christ made man-made governments
irrelevant all would be erased when the
Savior installed the millennial order
you will have no law but my law law when
I come one revelation informed the
saints how strange then that the prophet
of a movement that was extricated itself
from american society to wait the Second
Coming should end up entering his name
in candidacy for the presidency the
reason was this
needed the government after the
explosion of the Mormons from Jackson
County in 1833 Smith saw he could not
build his Zion without state protection
his tiny band of saints could not stand
alone against the wrath of the
communities where they lived without the
intervention of the state militia or
federal troops Mormons would be at the
mercy of their persecutors he needed
political support in other words to
bring in the millennial order almost
immediately after the news of the 1833
expulsion Smith saw he had to appeal to
the governor and when no aid was
forthcoming he went to President Andrew
Jackson locals were his enemy and his
hopeful expectation was that the higher
levels of government would enforce the
law Smith's revelations set him on this
course the principles of the
Constitution and protecting the people
and their rights came from heaven once
said that law of the land which is
constitutional supporting that principle
of freedom and maintaining rights and
privileges belongs to all mankind and is
justifiable before me when federal
officials pled lack of authority Smith
was furious Calhoun should ponder the
sublime idea that Congress with the
President as executor is as Almighty in
its sphere as Jehovah in his from an
irrelevance at the beginning of Smith's
predict political prophetic career
government became a necessity in God
squirt he threw himself in the
presidential race determined to protect
all abused minorities slaves and
prisoners as well as religious groups
like the Mormons but with the needs of
his own people foremost in his thinking
indifference to involvement then marked
Joseph Smith's political overall career
his overall political career as well as
this course of action in 1844 Smith was
a political innocent with little
interest in politics until the attacks
on his people required his involvement
but this is not the whole story when we
bring the book of mormon into the
picture a book published at the
beginning of his political career
smith's later interest in national
politics appears in a new light The Book
of Mormon was a political book its
profits were deeply involved with the
government and its concerns were more
national than individual if the Book of
Mormon represents Smith's thought in
1830 he had politics and good government
on his mind from the beginning from the
opening pages Authority rule and power
are at the forefront of the Book of
Mormon story Nephi the first prophet
recorder presents himself as the
mistreated younger son who suffered the
hands of his older brothers on one level
these brotherly battles seem familial
they ward as rivals siblings but the
same issue as laman and lemuel the
brothers sought was Authority who had
the right to govern the band of migrants
Nephi had taken charge when by custom
and right laymen should have succeeded
to his father's headship me if I wrote
his record as a political document to
demonstrate that he was the rightful
leader despite his status as a younger
brother the older to his account
insistently argued had forfeited their
rights of leadership by consistently
resisting their father they're inspired
younger brother and God that division
set up the framework for the entire book
the wars between Nephites and Lamanites
always turned on the question of Nephi's
user patient the great plot of the book
of mormon turned on the right to rule
from nephi on the narrative was
sustained by the interplay of prophecy
and politics politics was never far from
the action Kings Chief judges general
successions of power
changes in the form of government
dissenting factions political
assassinations civil-military relations
chips and the descent into anarchy when
government broke down all figured all
figure in the book for one span the
record keepers admitted politics from
their account to concentrate on the
spiritual but the separation did not
work without politics the history
foundered the recorders seemed to feel
superfluous and wrote less and less the
knee fight record revived only when the
record keepers began to talk again of
the nation's political life and turn the
record over to a king to keep from then
on the record came back to life what can
be said of political life in the Book of
Mormon hypothesizing that the book had
some influence on Joseph Smith's
thinking what was it over the years
commentators have pointed to the
fundamental alteration in the form of
government in the middle of the book
around 92 bc as a sign of its democratic
spirit at that point the government went
from a monarchy to government by judges
chosen by the voice of the people well
popular election of the judges certainly
as a democratic tone the results are not
something recognizably democratic inform
to begin with the monarchy was not
overthrown by popular demand or by
revolution as in American history the
sitting King relinquished the throne
against the wishes of his people they
wanted a king and he had to persuade
them government by judges was a more
secure form of government he installed a
chief judge with layers of lesser judges
blow him who were selected by the voice
of the people and then serve checks on
one another once chosen however the
voice of the people figured only
irregularly the chief judge served for
life and when he died the office passed
on to his son in kingly fashion moreover
the chief judge made the laws without
recourse to a legislature representation
did not figure at all in knee fight
government there was no Congress the
transition from monarchy to judges
judgeships was less a reenactment of the
American Revolution than a reversal of
ancient Israel's passage from government
by judges to rule by a king Israel's
prophets had resisted the popular desire
for king and only reluctantly agreed to
the anointing of salt the Book of Mormon
corrected that error in abolish kingship
and reinstated judges it's in serrated
inspiration seems to have been the
Hebrew Bible rather than the Declaration
of Independence and the Constitution the
Book of Mormon went back to the Hebrew
Bible on many accounts in his
preoccupation with righteousness for
example the underlying theme of the book
is the promise of prosperity and
well-being when righteousness prevails
in the threat of decline when wickedness
arises the political fate of the nation
hangs on its righteousness Mormon the
author of most of the book was forever
taking the moral temperature of the
nation were the people religious or
wicked and organized the story around
that perception everything followed from
that basic moral condition the nation
would prevail in battle and prosper
economically if the people shed their
pride and turn to God they hardened
their hearts ostentatiously displayed
their wealth neglected the poor and
built their lives on their riches
punishment surely followed the prophets
who kept the records are not always
kings or judges but they always consider
themselves the monitors of the nation's
goodness like the prophets and the
Hebrew Bible they think corporately and
focus intention on the righteousness of
rule
and the people as a whole religion and
the state are not separated in their
minds religion thoroughly infuses
thinking about the state the great issue
is the religious condition of the people
and their rulers if the righteous the
nation flourish flourishes if wicked it
will decline that is the way the Hebrew
Bible thought and it carries over to the
Book of Mormon defeat in battle was won
sure measure of the moral state of the
nation peace in politics was another
when wickedness infected society
factions arose and contention followed
the book of mormon values a politics of
harmony it makes no place for dissent
more often than not defeated two centers
fled the country and establish
themselves as Robert bands and the
mountains alternatively they sought to
overthrow the government to achieve
their ends and had to be suppressed they
resorted to assassination or alliances
with the enemy Lamanites to effect
change there seemed to be no concept of
loyal opposition as an ongoing and
possibly healthy element in government
dissent led to break down peace and
harmony was the only stable state so
strong are these themes in the book of
mormon they must have figured somehow in
Joseph Smith thinking when he began to
engage the government in 1833 to cast
Joseph Smith as a political innocent at
the outset should not imply he had no
national or governmental concerns he
began his religious leadership by
publishing a book steeped in politics
the prophets and record keepers in its
pages are morale monitors who constantly
scrutinized the people's righteousness
the translator of the Book of Mormon
could not have is it
engine could not help but have his
attention turned to the state of the
nation perhaps he felt at first the
nation was so far gone it was beyond
recovery Book of Mormon prophecies about
the future denounce American society but
to despair of national righteousness was
not the same as to pay no heed as the
heir of the Book of Mormon profits each
other's Smith would naturally think of
himself as an observer and a monitor of
American morality the state to the
nation must have been of some concern
keeping the Book of Mormon in mind we
cannot say that a presidential candidacy
was entirely foreign to Joseph Smith's
temperament as i intimated at the
beginning prophets in the book of mormon
had slipped in and out of government as
kings or chiefs judges why not a modern
prophet since he died before the
election and probably would not have
been elected any way we can scarcely
tell how we would have conducted himself
in office moreover the Book of Mormon
does not translate directly into
politics suitable for a modern state
likely Smith would not have felt
compelled to make the Book of Mormon the
strict template for the United States
anyway he was nothing if not inventive
The Book of Mormon is better understood
as a background influence shaping Smith
general attitudes rather than serving as
an exact template for his politics we
get an idea of how the Book of Mormon
shaped his thought by examining his 1844
political platform general Smith's views
of the powers and policy of the
government of the United States his
associate w w Phelps author the document
but Phelps probably thought as much like
Joseph Smith as any of his followers
when as the Prophet showed the platform
to his guests he expressed pride in the
document as if it were his own the
Navajo press printed 1,500 copies which
were mailed to president John Tyler
Tyler the Supreme Court justices all
members of Congress and newspapers all
over the country the 300 missionaries
sent out to promote Smith's candidacy
saw to printings in Pittsburgh
Philadelphia New York and Michigan views
was the face of Smith's campaign the
platform has been ransacked by modern
Mormons for hints about Joseph Smith's
opinions on 21st century political
issues modern Mormons rejoice in his
vigorous opposition of slavery and his
ingenious plan to buy out slaveholders
with revenues from the sale of the
public lands latter-day Saint Democrats
take comfort in his phrase the fostering
care of government applied to the
encouragement of industry through
tariffs in the establishment of a
national bank but efforts to identify
Joseph Smith's political position on
contemporary issues are no more
conclusive than the claims of both
Democrats and Republicans to the mantle
of Thomas Jefferson conditions in the
country of all are to fundamentally to
translate political views of the 1840s
to the 2010s we come closer to Joseph
Smith's perspective by attending to the
opening pages of the platform
characterized by one commentator as
Phelps turgid style the first two-thirds
of views can be read as Phelps and
Smith's attempts to blend their religion
with American Republican rhetoric views
sifts through the American political
tradition beginning with Benjamin
Franklin's plan of Union prepared for
the Albany convention of 1754 and
proceeding through the presidents from
John Adams to John Tyler Phelps and
Smith pick out passages from each of
these luminaries to create a Mormon
American political theological blend
Smith does not advertise his position
and
head of a growing Church in a presumed
profit of the latter days on the title
page he calls himself general Smith
acquired through his leadership of the
novel egin opposed to highly valued and
a tidally frequently used but if his
chosen title was secular Smith did not
conceal his religion or his church
connection his opening sentence set the
scene for the composition of the views
in his office with his brother and the
Twelve Apostles he spoke as a minister
when he referred to as double anxiety
for the happiness of all men both in
time and eternity at the conclusion he
promised unlike any other candidate in
that year that this son who laid down
his life for the salvation of all should
be supplicated by me for the good of all
people Smith did not hide the fact that
elected him the people would have chosen
a prophet President his aim was to blend
republicanism with religion views begins
with the Declaration of Independence
doctrine of equality and the incongruity
of holding two or three millions of
people as slaves for life because the
spirit of them is covered with a darker
skin than ours he puts the preamble to
the Constitution to the same use the
preambles assurance of the blessings of
liberty to ourselves and our posterity
man just what it said so the views puts
it without reference to color or
condition but even in drawing on these
American scriptures views of fuses it's
reading with the religious spirit
speaking of the nation the platform says
the main efforts of our officers ought
to be directed to ameliorate condition
of all black or white bond or free for
the rest of the book says best of books
says God made of one blood all nations
of men for to dwell on the face of the
earth here common Republican language
receives religious coloration officers
are servants of the people as Republican
is required but the foundation for the
principle of equality shifts from the
legal political doctrine of rights
to the scriptural assurance of creators
concern for all his creations what kind
of state what kind of politics emerges
from this hybrid language above all
views evokes a politics of harmony the
document extracts from the president's
from the past presidents words the
passages on unity and harmony it begins
with reference to Benjamin Franklin's
rather obscure 1754 plan of Union
apparently because of its name the word
Union occurs repeatedly through the text
Washington is represented by his famous
indictment of party politics and Joseph
Smith expands on it by saying unity is
power and when I reflect on the
importance of it to the stability of all
governments I am astounded at the silly
moves of persons and parties to foment
discord in order to ride into power on
the current a popular excitement
although the platform condensed slavery
the document opposes the abolitionists
because of their disruptive and
contentious mode of operation and all
this of course views takes a lead from
The Book of Mormons dislike of content
of contention the sure sign of social
and political decay Christ bluntly tells
the people The Book of Mormon people the
contentions of the devil the book sees
contention is the beginning of
treasonous dissent and ultimately civil
war that extreme opposition carries over
in views assessment of American society
it laments that democracy wigger and
clicker II will attract their elements
and foment divisions among the people to
accomplish fancies fancied schemes and
accumulate power Smith's vision of
society is based on a politics of
harmony how such a utopian politics as
ever the beach achieved however does not
concern the document it puts forward a
vision of how American government should
be without ever explaining how it could
arrive there it soon assumes that if all
are treated fairly and warmly if the
rights their rights are respected and
guaranteed people will happily cooperate
regarding the tense debate or the
admission of Texas views brightly offers
to welcome Texas into the Union in
Mexico too if it wishes to come my voice
would become come Texas come Mexico come
Canada and come all the world let us be
brethren let us be one great family and
let there be universal peace there is
nothing about the negotiation of
conflicting interests no reference to
national competition only kindness
respect and friendship the same for the
south here's a quote the southern people
are hospitable and Noble they will help
to read read so free a country of every
vestige of slavery whenever they are
assured of an equivalent of their
property views does not foresee a civil
war or even a clash of contending
interests purchased the slaves and
assumes and the south will gladly rid
itself of contending interests in the
demoralizing burden in the same spirit
prisoners will be transformed by a
change of environment let the
penitentiary has be turned into
seminaries of learning who are
intelligence like the angels of heaven
would banish such fragments of barbarism
the rosy picture of national politics
did not rise out of naivete The Book of
Mormon is a tragic account of an entire
civilization brought down by descent
class warfare and religious contention
Smith's own movement had been ridden by
conflict in Missouri a large proportion
of his own leadership defected and
citizens in the surrounding counties
rose up to drive the Saints from their
state as he rode in a letter from a
Missouri prison Smith knew it is the
nature into this position of all men
when they get a little power as they
suppose to exercise dominion over their
fellow beings but those harsh
experiences did not dim his desire for a
kingdom of peace and righteousness he
offered no path to this happy future
other than a series of policies to
alleviate the miseries of slaves and
prisoners and a few others to increase
the prosperity of the nation his
contribution was a prophetic vision not
a blueprint for change Smith's theology
is noted for its high anthropology he
thought humans had the seeds of godhood
within them and in time they would enjoy
the fullness of godly power we can see
that exalted optimism at work in views
the discouraging realities of American
politics did not weaken his hope for a
union of hearts and minds ruled by
benevolence and virtue he conceived his
role not as a policy expert to create a
blueprint or a politician to win an
election but as a prophet like his
predecessors in the Book of Mormon to
tell a society of its own possibilities
the appeal of those ideas in the
election of 1840 for was never tested
four months before the election while
his core of missionaries was promoting
his candidacy across the land Smith was
shot by a mob a victim of the of the
hatred that he had yearned to dispel
thanks
you